[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti oggi parlerò di un
tema molto caldo molto cops molto sexy
come lo definisce un mio collega
olandese il cibo del futuro è un
argomento molto importante sia per noi
che per le generazioni future
negli ultimi anni
tutti noi siamo stati testimoni abbiamo
assistito a eventi terribili incendi che
hanno devastato
il cuore della nostra pianeta le foreste
dei casi più eclatanti è stato sono
stati gli incendi in amazzonia o in
australia
nell'estate del
ma di chi è la colpa
diciamo è colpa loro delle mucche perché
delle mucche
tutti noi abbiamo abbiamo sentito
parlare che le mucche sono uno dei
principali responsabili
per i cambiamenti climatici
se fossero un paese le mucche
sarebbero il sesso paese al mondo per
emissioni di metano davanti a paesi come
italia giappone
francia germania e brasile
però è anche un po colpa nostra cioè io
in questi dieci minuti più o meno che mi
rimangono 12 gli chiederei di rinunciare
di una cosa che sia sacra per voi
toscani e la fiorentina
sa perché colpa nostra perché arati
agricoltura richiede
enorme quantità di terra
e le foreste le zone umide le savane
sono quelli che immagazzinano assorbono
il carbonio e abbattendo le foreste per
far spazio alle fattorie
alla terra coltivabile
non facciamo altro che
trasformare
l'ecosistema le foreste in una fonte di
carbonio ormai un terzo 33 per cento
della terra libera di ghiacci
viene utilizzata per allevare il
bestiame
in più
la carne di manzo
richiede molti più risorse molte più
terra per produrre un grammo di proteina
rispetto al carne di maiale di pollo o
addirittura delle fagioli che sono una
alternativa di proteina vegetale
ad aggravare il problema è anche la
crescente popolazione globale
secondo alcune previsioni entro
2050 saremo più di 9 miliardi di persone
con risorse sempre più scarse
acque inquinate
terra che sarà poco disponibile da
convertire in terra da pascolo
surriscaldamento globale
la domanda è come affrontare
questo problema è un problema molto
serio
tenendo conto del fatto che già oggi
ci sono circa 800 milioni di persone che
soffrono la fame
gli chiedo di cambiare di rinunciare
all'hamburger e alla fiorentina
ma esiste un'alternativa che sia
sostenibile
ricca di proteine di alto valore
nutrizionale
alla carne convenzionale
l'alternativa esiste
o dio se questa è la prima relazione
oddio
è di solito le persone dicono sì ma non
per questo
li senti questa è l'alternativa è il
cibo del futuro perché gli insetti
perché gli insetti sono
12 volte più efficienti in convertire il
mangime in carne e di bile commestibile
12 volte più efficienti delle mucche
quattro volte più efficiente dei maiali
è due volte più efficienti dai poli in
più gli insetti per dire per darvi
qualche esempio i grilli richiedono
meno acqua e vengono allevati in
fattorie
molto compatte
come mai allora nonostante tutti i
benefici nutrizionali
e anche l'impatto molto positivo per la
pianeta la stramaggioranza
dei consumatori occidentali
non percepiscono gli insetti e ingrid in
particolare come un'alternativa al cibo
convenzione al carnet convenzionale
perché nella storia dell'umanità nessuno
ha mai comprato qualcosa per i suoi
benefici
quello che mangiamo quello che decidiamo
di mettere il nostro piatto sul nostro
piatto non è solo frutto di meccanismi
biologici come il gusto alla fame
ci sono anche altri fattori culturali
sociali che influiscono le nostre scelte
il fattore principale
l'ostacolo principale la barriera di
adozione principale
e il pregiudizio culturale la schema per
dire
il fattore principale a livello
psicologico
trovato grazie alla ricerca che stiamo
facendo anche oggi è il disgusto il
disgusto che una reazione automatica
inconscia del sistema immunitario
che ha come obiettivo quello di
proteggerci di far sì che noi evitiamo
il contatto
l'interazione il consumo
di sostanze che sono ponte
potenzialmente nocive
allora noi come persone e io come marchi
tir come anche come ogni uno scienziato
noi dobbiamo trovare un modo per se non
eliminare almeno in qualche modo
abbassare queste barriere di adozione
quale potrebbe essere l'eroe del giorno
quale potrebbe essere lo strumento alla
scienza che ci permetterebbe di
abbassare queste barriere se non
eliminandoli del tutto il marketing
io dico il marketing
molti di voi probabilmente quando
pensano al marketing pensano male
il male del xxi secolo quello che causa
il fenomeno del consumismo
per dirne uno invece
noi e il mio gruppo di ricerca
grazie a queste ricerche abbiamo fatto
vedere che il marketing può essere anche
uno strumento molto importante
per
cambiare
il modo in cui i consumatori pensano e
agiscono
il marketing può essere uno strumento
importantissimo per risolvere
tantissimi problemi
sociali culturali quelli che richiedono
interventi soluzioni immediate
cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo utilizzato
strumenti di marketing e new roman
keating un approccio multi metodo dove
abbiamo combinato
strumenti di marketing tradizionale con
quelli di neuromarketing
visto il mio background i
neuroscienziati io cerco di applicare
questi strumenti ha quasi tutto quello
che faccio nella mia ricerca
cosa il mio no marketing per quelli di
voi che non conoscono questa nuova
scienza è un po creo è un mix tra
psicologia marketing e neuroscienze
praticamente quello che facciamo e di
prendere tutte le teorie strumenti
metodologie e approcci dalla psicologia
dal marketing e della neuroscienza
mischiarli bene
e applicarli per risolvere
problemi sia aziendali che culturali e
sociali
in più in questa ricerca abbiamo
collaborato con un'azienda un
pluripremiato produttore
di prodotti alimentari a base di insetti
non in italia
difficilissimo due italiani che hanno
fondato un'azienda nel regno unito a uk
la commozione con questa azienda è stata
molto utile per noi perché ci ha
permesso di capire quali sono i
fondamenti le basi
qual è il punto da dove dobbiamo
iniziare a studiare il comportamento le
risposte dei consumatori
al cibo a base di insetti
in più
loro ci hanno anche offerto
gratuitamente i prodotti quelli prima
degli interventi che li abbiamo
suggeriti e anche dopo
per poter confrontare per poter fare un
test sul mercato e in più e questa è la
parte che diciamo io apprezzo moltissimo
e in più sono stati anche disposti di
adottare di implementare di cambiare il
loro marketing mix le loro azioni di
marketing sulla base dei risultati della
nostra ricerca
cosa abbiamo trovato allora di quelli di
voi che sanno qualcosa di marketing il
punto di partenza è quello sempre quello
di segmentare il mercato di fare una
segmentazione cioè di capire quale sia
la popolazione del mercato del segmento
del mercato con più alta probabilità di
adottare una innovazione cioè non parlo
di se ti parlo di innovazione perché
questa è una fazione di una innovazione
in generale i cosiddetti innovatori
quali sono
e noi abbiamo trovato che lo stile di
vita delle persone
e molto importante
per il disgusto che loro provano verso i
prodotti a base di insetti sempre di
prodotti alimentari a base di insetti e
anche a un impatto molto importante
sulla loro scelta di provare i prodotti
perché il problema sta lì provando
perché non è che il cracker di insetti o
le patatine di insetti o la farina di
insetti ha un gusto diverso di quello
normale no il problema e provare noi
abbiamo come obiettivo quello di far
provare di convincere i consumatori a
provare il prodotto perché dopo averlo
provato poi lo vedete tutti voi
il gusto è sempre lo stesso non cambia e
la percezione sono le aspettative su cui
noi dobbiamo lavorare
lo stile di vita
è un fattore molto importante che
influisce sulle scelte del consumatore e
noi abbiamo visto che i consumatori che
sono meno attenti alla salute
sono quelli che ti mostrano
il disgusto più basso quasi nullo verso
i prodotti a base di insetti ed amici
cosa vuol dire tonici
cracker
patatine biscotti fatti con la farina a
base di 7
questo è il nostro primo
diciamolo criterio di segmentazione che
le aziende dovrebbero utilizzare per
targetizzare con il giusto marketing mix
personalizzato e cosa intendiamo per
marketing mix lo vedremo tra poco cioè
quali sono le azioni di marketing che le
aziende dovrebbero implementare per far
sì che quel segmento del mercato
provo il prodotto
questo è il primo esempio
sul packaging del prodotto sulla
confezione
abbiamo visto che l'immagine
dell'insetto porta a un ingusto una
risposta un disgusto più alto una
risposta negativa più alta perciò
abbiamo suggerito l azienda dovreste
eliminare l'immagine dell'insetto
e questo noi abbiamo visto che porta ai
risultati molto positivi
però a breve termine
il nostro obiettivo non è lavorare su
breve termine ma sul lungo termine
allora quello che abbiamo suggerito e
questa è stato uno studio successivo le
aziende di non di eliminare del tutto
l'immagine di insetto del packaging
perché in questo modo i consumatori
percepiscono questa azione di marketing
come una nazione ingannevole c'è un modo
per ingannare il consumatore e questo ha
effetti negativi a lungo termine
abbiamo suggerito le aziende di cambiare
e di stilizzare di rendere l'immagine di
nizzetto più ma
in questo caso noi abbiamo trovato non
solo effetti positivi cioè per gli
effetti positivi intendo riduzione del
disgusto ma anche a lungo termine
cioè cercando di eliminare la idea che
i prodotti a base di insetti sono un
solo un prodotto deviante delle norme
occidentali è un prodotto nuovo
e questa strategia ci permette di farlo
ultimo punto della presentazione
tantissime aziende
basano la loro strategia di
comunicazione
sui benefici
utilitaristici chiamiamoli così cioè sul
fatto che i prodotti a base di insetti
prodotti alimentari a base di insetti
sono ricchi di proteine
molto nutrizionali e fanno bene al
pianeta
sono molto sostenibile il consumatore
non se ne frega
in questo caso l'alternativa sarebbe
quella di comunicare cioè di cercare di
posizionare il prodotto sulla base dei
benefici e doni c
che il consumo di un prodotto del genere
può portare alle persone
per esempio essere q
essere diverso essere originale essere
innovativo essere il primo questi sono i
messaggi che le aziende devono cercare
di comunicare ai potenziali acquirenti
per convincerli a provare il prodotto
perché vi ricordo l'obiettivo qua è
sempre quello di provare a una volta ho
provato
garantisco che sarà il vostro nuovo
amore il prodotto qualsiasi prodotto sia
in più e questa è l'ultima cosa che
vorrei condividere con voi in più
abbiamo visto che l'utilizzo di una
lingua straniera cioè invece di scrivere
mangiate gli insetti e fico
scriverlo in inglese in inglese per
esempio i teen sex xq abbassa in modo
automatico inconscio la risposta
negativa cioè il disgusto percepito dei
consumatori verso il prodotto
stranamente
per chiudere il messaggio che vorrei
condividere con tutti voi
tre volte al giorno per alcuni dino
anche di più anche per me però in media
tre volte al giorno decidiamo cosa è
mettere
sul nostro piatto cosa mangiare cosa
comprare dei supermercati quale
industrie finanziare
dobbiamo cambiare per dare un futuro a
noi e anche le prossime generazioni
grazie
[Applauso]